so if if uh you know what what should
the average person be buying like a time
right
uh well let me let me slow down we were
previously talking about
a dramatic change in that in the system
let's start from there what
what does this change look like do you
think right we've talked a lot about
like balkanization
yeah where the and i want to be clear on
this it's like the political factions
basically choose their specific region
and they they break apart and move
do you think it's something like that
what do you think we're looking at um so
you know first of all i don't want to
really be certain about this um i always
find people who are absolutely certain
to be a little you know if you've got a
head scratching attitude about that that
you know
i don't know man you haven't seen the
future um but i think the interesting
thing about information technology
whether we're talking about the
gutenberg press or whether we're talking
about you know tcp or twitter or
whatever
is that it connects people who are
further and further apart with lower and
lower latency
so if you want to look at like 1776 um
you know people
in different towns in massachusetts had
a lot more in common with each other
than they had with people
back in you know wales or you know
various parts of england
because they can only communicate with a
few letters you know with a latency of
six months or so
and so that made it very easy for the
regions to sort of grow apart and have
their own uh political cultures
and the weird thing about the high-speed
connection we have is that we have
you know uh two tribes obviously red and
blue but then a lot more tribes you know
if you go to you know some furry fandom
thing right yellow
you know you pick anything whether it's
you know mustang uh
engine you know modification community
or whether it's
uh preppers or whether you know it's any
guns yeah you'll find that these tribes
are geographically distributed
um so i think that we might be headed to
a world where the westphalian nation
state where all of the nations have
crisp little borders around them
is perhaps fading and we're going to a
new world where the tribes are
interleaved and distributed across and
on top of each other
i've been thinking a lot about that
dissolution of the nation state since
about 2006
really since internet video when i
realized how powerful and connected we
are now with video chat like
how do you see it happening without uh
because the downside was i don't want
a one world government that's
totalitarian right now i'm looking at
more of a decentralized localization
i mean obviously you work with crypto
like how do you see something like that
right um you know again you know i'm
gonna say i can speculate since you're
asking me to speculate
uh you know if you go back to the
medieval period there's this interesting
thing
where there was less of a crisp boundary
in the westphalian sense you might have
somebody who was a
you know the example i i said before the
show started
is you can imagine that um there was
someone you know pedaling out on the
street and the guards come up and say
hey it's sunday you can't sell stuff and
he you know holds up his warrant and he
says you know actually i'm a jew
so i'm you know bound by different uh uh
doctrine doctrine right religious code
um but
i'm also tied in a little bit to your
political system and i've got a warrant
from the duke who says you know yes i'm
a jew with his permission i'm doing
things
and the answer is oh okay so you're on
the same territory as people who are
under this other power but you're under
a different sort of chain of command
whoa and um i can't imagine that being a
good thing
um you know when the world changes good
or bad doesn't really matter you know it
comes out of incentives
i think it might be a decent thing um i
think we're going that way
yeah i mean you look at the the racial
identitarianism from the establishment
in this country and it really does look
like that's where we're going yeah i
mean you know right now we're already in
that you know one person at harvard uh
is under a different law than someone
else depending on you know his skin
color um you know his admission there
the behavioral norms that's expected and
everything else
or actually you can't even get into
harvard if you're asian right
so right yeah absolutely different
different roles just based on what you
look like
and uh you know i there's little hints
of that that you know if someone is from
overseas and they've got diplomatic
plates we're here you know not too far
from dc and i saw that
so i think that polycentric law
overlapping in the same geographic
location is something that has happened
before in the middle ages and i think it
could happen again not
not making a strong prediction uh and
this ties into we're talking about
anarcho-capitalism and one of the sort
of leading luminaries
um of anarcho-capitalism is david
friedman the son of milton friedman
and he's written a bunch of great books
on the topic uh the
seminal one is the machinery of freedom
which was one of the books that along
with robert hineland's the moon is a
harsh mistress
really sort of created my world view but
he's written some other good ones
law's order and uh one i read a few
months ago was legal systems very
different from our own
so uh i'm not sure we'll see what
happens over the coming decades i could
see like um an augmented reality system
where
when you look around people have like a
different aura if they're under
different jurisdiction
or something but my my wonder is what if
the power goes out would that system
function
could it function do you think it was
something that um you know uh what if
the power goes out gets back to sort of
robustness and anti-fragility
and uh you know i expect that long-term
uh technology is gonna stick around
and that we will be living in a
hyper-networked world
so that that sort of pulls in the
opposite direction of the sort of
localism and the anti-fragile
homesteading that we're talking about so
uh
i don't know um you know in investing
some people talk about a barbell
strategy where you want to have a lot of
your money
and sort of safe reasonable things like
index funds but you also want to
have a small amount and really potential
high payoff bets and you know this is
the venture capital model and uh
politically uh looking towards the
future on the one hand you know sort of
i hope for everyone has you know human
rights and the uh power grid stays up
and the food supplies are good
uh but i also have sheep that i can eat
in my own orchard and i can make my own
wine in case it goes bad
we gotta get off the grid the central so
we're getting off a centralized economy
centralized law centralized electricity
it's got to be
so let's let's let's central you you
know a lot about rome
uh i know samia when when rome collapsed
right the the
as you mentioned before latency distance
between communications was was very a
very long time absolutely and then you
end up with their own political cultures
and then
you mentioned now we're in this you know
new era of technology
it's gonna be really interesting in my
opinion just to elaborate on that idea
when you have
you know one faction of people maybe
it's a family
and they're anarcho-capitalists and
they're online communicating with the
anarcho-capitalist community
but they're decentralized their neighbor
is a socialist
their other neighbor is a conservative
you know you know free enterprise sort
of but still some government control
how how how will there be cohesive raw
if people when right next to each other
are just
yeah it's a great question and i'll take
a stab at answering it but
again i want to be clear that i'm not
predicting that like this is definitely
the way it's gonna happen
uh david friedman talked about this and
uh he's the one who came up with sort of
polycentric legal order and what he said
is you know
uh you tim you know might subscribe to
one legal system where you want to keep
trespassers off your land that's pretty
important to you
uh someone else might subscribe to a
legal system that has a english right to
rome
and then we uh in england apparently if
you've got a certain amount of land you
can't keep people off of it they
they're allowed to just walk right
across as the sort of traditional uh
right of the englishman
so what happens when these you know
things come in conflict like one guy
says i've got an
absolute right to walk across your
backyard and you say i've got an
absolute right to keep you out
and you know theoretically someone who
wanted to dis on anarcho-capitalism
would say well you know and then of
course you'd get a gun battle and that's
why anarcho-capitalism is the worst
possible political ideological
ideology in the world um but you know
in in the real world when corporations
run into things like you know you've
stolen my intellectual property because
i think that my patent on you know how
resistors work is you know blah blah
blah and you say no
i'm using a different thing it looks
similar but it's not we
don't get guns and duke this out uh we
you know we just hire lawyers and they
settle it
uh so i think that that would happen now
so now the next parity is okay
travis is arguing that any time two
people have a disagreement
about uh trespassing in a garden like is
there an easement or is there not then
there's a 90 000
lawsuit that takes three years and i i
think uh
there's game theory where when something
is iterated
there is not a need to hash it out time
and time and time again
both sides see you know really a
negotiated solution here and some rules
of the road make sense
so if you look at any place where uh
firms interact
they either come up with their own laws
or they come up with their own
governance bodies to help them interact
with each other because
you know if you look at evolution
animals don't battle to the death with
each other when you've got two rams and
they both want to you know
dominate the herd of use it doesn't make
sense if one ram is aiming to kill the
other because he's likely to get
severely damaged in that the
uh utility maximizing compromise is some
sort of dominance display and head
bashing and then one of them sucks off
because he can live to try again another
day and i i think people are not idiots
people do not get into gun battles they
i i i somewhat disagree um you look we
we talked about the wacky laws you know
recently where you've got some places
where it's like you can't take a shower
on tuesdays
and it actually made sense because back
in the day the local aquifer was like
you know
we like they said we have to have one
day where nobody uses water so it can
replenish a little bit
but now we have better water systems we
have tons of water
so we we produce these laws based on the
specifics that are happening
in our areas so you have a community and
they build a culture
they build rules and laws with before
each other by each other and sometimes
and disagree with each other but
understanding the problem
hey look a bear keeps coming in so we're
going to pass a law you can't have
picnic baskets lying around wherever
well now you've got somebody who's on
the internet and he does not subscribe
to
any of his immediate community when they
go outside they're clashing
and one guy's on nothing but socialist
forms and one guy's not nothing but you
know ancap forums
and so they're completely at odds
locally
i don't necessarily uh think that they
would just agree to resolve the solution
because the resolution itself is part of
the local community and culture
and law that's a great argument uh and i
follow it and it's convincing and um
so now the great thing about you know
pontificating while sitting on my butt
is i can say okay if you didn't like
that answer i've got another one
and the other one is that just as the
cost of information transmission is
falling
the cost of picking up and moving your
butt is falling
uh you know i moved from massachusetts
where the local community and the norms
and the politics were very much not to
my liking and i moved to new hampshire
eight years ago
and uh a lot of end caps in new
hampshire there are uh
there's a joke um you know i don't know
if i would necessarily say that i'm part
of the free state project but i'm
certainly
fsp adjacent and i know a lot of people
um
and there's a joke you know what's the
difference between a libertarian and cap
and the answer is you know six months in
new hampshire
so uh you know i think picking up and
moving to be around people who are like
you
um is a good thing and there's a phrase
the great sort which is mostly talking
about demographics and mating but i
think that to some degree it's also
happening geographically
i completely agree i mean look at how
many people moved to texas recently
right joe rogan ellen musk announced it
but a ton of people
there's a lot of regular people that
moved and one of the things i've warned
though is that while you know joe rogan
and elon musk
are they seem to be left-leaning
individuals i mean elon musk calls
himself a socialist whether he is or not
i don't know
it's funny considering he's he's a
master troll that's right right right
but the the people they bring with them
when they move their companies and their
jobs they bring
people with them in their periphery who
are definitely
not going to agree with exactly what
happens there in texas
but i digress you know that being said i
do think there's a great sort happening
i mean look we were
we moved effectively to west virginia i
was living in new york city only a few
years ago
moved to the philly suburbs now we're in
the the mountains you know essentia
essentially i say that because we're
trying to by the way i loved the drive
out so the deer every day i look outside
there's a family a deer doing their
thing
and uh you know i want to get away from
the city so we move closer and closer to
people who are
more and more like-minded for me i would
say it's not necessarily that the people
around here are are like-minded
but we agree to leave each other alone
right which is big
yeah absolutely where i keep finding a
the problem or a problem regarding this
whole concept of decentralized law
is if a community wants to pollute the
air
because that can affect the entire globe
if it's done on a mass enough scale
if they're pumping methane and carbon
and you know radioactive materials up
into the atmosphere to produce just pure
industry like hundreds of thousands of
people
like for decades could just destroy
things like thousands of miles away
from china or polluting the water like
in the ocean like dumping
so a lot of the plastic wastes in
indianapolis i was gonna go there next
yeah indian china plastic
we've got all of these rules against
having you know plastic straws in the
u.s and really it's all coming from just
one small place so
are we ultimately will we need a global
like an overseer
um so you know my answer to this
is that uh freedom can only exist on the
frontier
and you know america has got a really
unique libertarian culture you find a
few libertarians in other places but
it's endemic to uh you know the united
states um
and that's because of our culture we we
ran into a you know quote-unquote empty
uh which is you know
the western hemisphere was empty because
of the tragedy of uh communicable
diseases
but uh we evolved this idea of a
frontier because we had a frontier and
that's why you can sort of
never really communicate about some of
these topics with people in other parts
of the country
and so if i may plug something else um
tim introduced me as an author and the
first things i wrote before the
homesteading books
were two anarcho-capitalistic novels
which pretty much have the thesis
uh that we can only achieve freedom out
on the frontier so the first one is the
powers of the earth which won the
prometheus award for best novel in
2018 and the sequel is causes of
separation
which won the prometheus award in 2019.
i think you are correct about that with
the freedom
um the way i've described it is you know
you know how uh gases the molecules you
know are bouncing around quite a bit
liquids a little bit and then solids
they're rigid
when you look at big cities i view it as
a solid all of these individuals stacked
on top of each other
and that that room to bounce around
erratically that's your freedom
yep the more people surround you the
more you push and it compresses
your sphere of freedom so it's it's
actually it's a really really easy way
to explain it
i i love your analogy and uh because i'm
a nerd i'm going to make it a little
nerdier
the ideal gas law which is pv equals nrt
and uh you know it's a great analogy
because
uh one thing that happens when you add
more uh molecules that have this kinetic
energy or when you crush them in tighter
space
is the temperature goes up right and um
yeah absolutely
oh yeah or the system it expands right
right you know so we can go to the sort
of the carnot cycle that it pushes out
and uh you know
the piston but we're we're talking about
compression so that energy is getting
released
yeah and uh the easiest way to explain
it is just playing the drums
that in order to play the drums you need
a massive sphere of
freedom you can't do it in the suburbs
you might be able to but you have to get
permission
hey you guys mind if we're playing the
drums i know you know the the the zoning
order laws say that
the ordinance says i can be noisy until
10 pm but then your neighbors get mad at
you and then you're fighting with your
neighbors
you talk to them they'll say okay play
the drums but only between this hours or
are you okay
make noise put on between those hours
you can't play drums in the city right
you got you got
one person above you one to your left
your right and one behind you
and you play the drums and they're going
to be like are you nuts
it's it's it's not about i can sort of
hear it it's you're literally banging
next to next door to me
like turn your music it's a movie trope
so people
people are stacked on top of each other
there's no room for freedoms
i i absolutely agree um one of the
you know there's a dozen or five dozen
reasons that i don't want to live in a
city and i can't stand the city
but one of them is that i'm an introvert
and um you know
i i know people who often propose
systems like i've got one friend who is
proposing a hacker space and my answer
to a hackerspace is i have a hackerspace
it's my garage and i've got you know
mig welders and you know bandsaws and
lathes and everything i want to do and
so anytime i want to do a project
the tools are there and i'm first in
line and i don't have to wait for anyone
else
and i think that uh one of the reasons
that he likes the idea of the
hackerspace is because
all of these things are up for
negotiation we get to come together as a
community and decide the rules for how
we should do this we get to come
together as community
so what i would see as a cost which is
the interactions and the negotiations is
for him a benefit
and i think a lot of people who love
cities actually love the fact that you
have to negotiate everything
um you know they talk about you know a
certain sense of community
and you know that and that's what makes
new york city great the fact that when
you know
one person vomits on the subway that
everyone else helps everyone else walk
around it
um and uh i i don't like interacting so
if i want to play the drums and get my
meal pureed on
you know i don't have to talk to 10
other people about it thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you